please state your name and your business
address
tyler
adam
sir what is your occupation
[Music]
i'm a police officer for the city of los
angeles
so you arrived at the scene at 8 57 p.m
correct
right what did you do then
we
walked to the location
do you recall
anything that you did before you went up
to the penthouse
uh we walked in and
met with security who showed us where
the elevator was
did you do anything else
but your best recollection is that you
went in you talked to security
and then you went on an elevator is that
right
yes
do you recognize the person in this
picture on hadden exhibit number 24
as the person
who was the
the uh subject of
your and officer signs
uh reporting to
the eastern columbia building that
evening
correct all right so let's go to uh
exhibit number 24 um
and do you
what do you see in this picture with
respect to whether there is any injury
depicted on misheard i see a uh even a
white fair skin with uh
i'm sorry
[Music]
pink cheeks
and pink eyes
all right
do you
recognize that as a potential injury on
her face
knowing what our investigation revealed
no it's that pink's consistent with
brian
what do you mean by what your
investigation revealed
that it was a
verbal dispute
and she refused that she had any injury
is there any other
goal
for business opportunity
that mr depp
has lost
since
you started representing him in october
2016.
i would say
his
um
[Music]
i would say yes
what
the pirates the the next pirates movie
do you remember which one that was
six seven i'm not sure what the number
is
hit six i think pirate six is the one
that's he had to come up with
and
why
what is your understanding of why
mr depp
lost pirate six
my opinion
is that it was related to the
accusations
um
that amber has made
and what is your opinion based on
excuse me
what is your opinion based on
um
conversations with
colleagues and studios
i'm sorry i didn't quite hear you
conversations with studios and
other executives both
internal and external
when you say related to the accusations
that were made by amber heard against mr
deaf are you talking about accusations
of domestic violence and abuse by mr
jeff
yes
um
how many conversations have you had with
studio
and other executives
i have no idea
more than five more than ten
um
i don't know about more than ten
probably between five and ten
do you recall speaking with
at studios
or other executives
um
jerry bruckheimer
probably mostly jerry and then
colleagues at caa
when did you first have any
conversations with jerry buckham about
pirate six and mr
i have no idea
do you recall whether it was in 2016
2017 2018 2019.
i don't
when did you have any conversations with
colleagues at ca
it would have been whenever the
decisions were being made about how to
cast that movie i don't i don't honestly
i don't know what year that was
do you recall who you spoke with at cna
i spoke with jack wiggum i spoke with
brian
what do you recall jerry bruckheimer
telling you
um
[Music]
i i don't recall the specific
conversations
but the
nature of it was that the studio
was
having difficulty employing him
and did mr bruckheimer
tell you why the studio was having
difficulty employing mr duff
um
no not specifically but it was
understood
did you ask
i didn't need to
why did you think you didn't need to
because
everyone was aware of what was garnering
the
attention of the studios and determining
whether or not he could be employed
you testified just
a few minutes ago that it was your
opinion that mr depp
lost
the pirate six movie because of
misheard's allegations is that accurate
allegations of abuse correct
yes
and
is this a demonstration of
when
disney made that decision to not
uh hire mr deb for pirate sticks
yes
except 22.
did you ever see
mr death
more physically abused misheard
no did miss herd ever tell you that she
had been physically abused by mr death
no did you did mr depp ever tell you
that he had physically abused miss hurt
no
no
did you ever witness
um any
injuries on misheard that would indicate
that she was physically abused
no
now again this is
a few months after the filing of the
divorce papers
and the tro
and miss heard states to you i'll call
you right back sorry
and you say okay
she says is it too late to call
and you say just finishing dinner we'll
call you as soon as we walk out within
20.
and she says please tell him
i love him
is that an accurate reading of the text
exchange so far
yes
do you know if at this time
based on your relationship with miss
hurt and mr depp
[Music]
whether
miss heard wanted to reconcile with mr
dev
yes
did you understand that she did
yes
did
miss heard
based on your personal friendship with
miss her close personal friendship with
miss heard
would you say
that she confided in you
yes
and what about mr yes
mr craig at some point in time
after ms heard
filed his divorce papers in may of 2016.
um did she
make any requests of you to
intervene in
uh the relationship between her and mr
bib
what do you mean by intervene
assist in let's start with assistant
communications between the two
same objections
can you explain to me what transpired in
that regard
walk me through
at some point around that time
she wanted
me to arrange for them to get together
in person
and
what did you do
after that was requested of you by mr
i
talked to johnny about it what happened
after that
he was reluctant
at first and then agreed
and then what happened after that
i mean this long time ago but
i remember
there was a fair amount of discussion
about
the tro
and how we would deal with that because
nobody wanted
johnny accused of violating the tro
as an outcome of
that meeting
and i don't remember exactly what we
did
but amber at some point warranted that
she would never accuse him of violating
the tro to do the meeting
and i set the meeting up
so just so i understand
you set the meeting up
at the request of miss heard
objections
um
and as part of you setting up
she told you that
it didn't matter what i'm trying to
understand what what was the issue with
respect to the tro
my understanding of
restraining order at least at the time
was that
he couldn't go within a certain
distance of
her
okay
and what was her suggestion
um
with respect to that issue
in connection with her wanting to meet
with him
she
promised me and told me to relay to him
that she would never accuse him
of violating
the restraining order
as a result of agreeing to meet her and
i believe but i don't
recall exactly there were conversations
with
both
sides legally i believe at the time
to make it transparent to everybody that
this was happening
okay
and then what happened next
um i arranged the meeting
johnny was in
san francisco
on tour
and i arranged to borrow a friend's
house
and
amber and i flew to
san francisco and drove to the house
and
johnny showed up a few hours later
and did the two of them meet
yes
in the same room
they sat outside
okay
uh
how close to each other were they
inches away from each other
and how long uh
were they out there talking for how long
were they out there talking
several hours
did you although you were out there did
you
were you in a position where you could
see them through a window or otherwise
yes
at some point in time the conversation
ended correct
correct and what happened after that
i
received a call or a text from
uh steve whose house it was
and he
notified me that
he would be coming back
to the house
within the next hour or so
and
i told
johnny and amber
and we decided to rent a hotel room in
san francisco
so that they could continue to talk
and did that in fact happen
objection
and at some point in time you left that
house correct to go to san francisco
yes
and was it the three of you
no
johnny had security with him
and
we talked about the fact that they
it wouldn't be
a good idea for them to be seen together
there
so
johnny left with his security in his car
and i believe
amber and i took an uber
and what happened after that
[Music]
we all met at the hotel
room
and do you know what happened after that
um they started arguing
and do you recall any details of the
argument
no and for how long were you was this
argument had in a in a hotel room
yes
did you witness the entire discussion or
did you leave at some point
i left the next morning at
five
o'clock in the morning or six o'clock in
the morning
and mr carino um i'm showing you emails
over produced by you first uh the bottom
of the first page it starts at the
bottom of the first page the
string above it was redacted and you'll
see that it starts on august 7th 2017 do
you see that
august 7th 2017. yes having read it
can you determine who you're speaking
with in this text exchange amber oh hang
on let me ask you this
do you know whether or not um
miss herd ever
had a relationship with mr elon musk
yes
she did
yes so again it's dated
august
of 2017
um
and she says dealing with breakup
i hate when things go public
see i'm so sad
having reviewed the document again do
you have an understanding of what she's
referencing there
i believe she's referring to breaking up
with elon
you say it seems like a press release
you weren't in love with him and you
told me a thousand times you were just
filling space
what are you saying there
i'm saying
why would you be sad if you weren't in
love with them to begin with
and by him you're referring to who
elon
just to uh
authenticate this document again mr
queen do you see that
it's referenced at the bottom bait stamp
cc indicating that you produced this
document yes
and um
having read this do you do you perceive
this as a transgress copy of the text
exchange between you and mr ms heard
yes
okay
and i will um
can you see the very top here it's dated
august 16 2017
and misheard states to you
i written so many notes
can you give him one
i don't know how or where to start
there's no way to begin and
all i have to say but i have so many
finally i am single clear in my heart
and mind i just want him to know i loved
loved him and that i am sorry
do you have an understanding of who ms
hurd is referring to here yes
and who is miss her referring to in this
text johnny
and what is she um
asking you to do here
she was asking me to
deliver
a letter
that she was writing to him
and
did she also want you to and it says and
that i am sorry
uh what was your understanding of what
she was asking you to do there if
anything
i believe that was all in reference to
getting him
a handwritten letter that she was
writing or trying to write was it your
understanding at the time of this text
exchange august 24 2017 that miss amber
was attempting to reconcile with mr deb
i believe so
okay
and i know maybe this may sound
repetitive but
on august 20 at the time of this text on
august 24 2017
um you and her were still close personal
friends correct
i believe so
there's not much here at all um
mr cranial but i did want to confirm
that this was a document produced by you
correct based on the bait stamp on the
bottom
yes
and
do you see it's dated september 27 2017
september 23rd
oh you're right i apologize
it's dated september 23 2017 and it's a
text to you that says god i miss him
do you have an understanding of uh
what
not
who ms hurt is referring to there
yes
and who's that
johnny
and
do you see um at the bottom
the date of the text is june 9th 2018
yes
okay
uh it says i text him happy birthday
do you know who sent that and who the
him is i assume this is from amber and
she's talking about johnny